well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look then at what
is on the front pages of tomorrow's
papers
in the next half hour we'll see what's
making the headlines with the consultant
editor of the daily mail andrew pierce
and the associate editor of the daily
mirror kevin mcguire lovely to see both
hello
as ever then to the front pages the
guardian to start with
leading with the announcement of an
independent inquiry into the pandemic
and many people's dissatisfaction that
it won't happen until next year
the metro understands boris johnson is
the subject of a 535 pound
county court judgment the nature of the
alleged debt is unknown downey street
has said the claim is
without merit and the prime minister
plans to appeal
according to the telegraph if new nhs
guidance is to be followed
virtual gp appointments could become the
norm
even after the pandemic masks in
shops and offices won't be necessary
after june the 21st that's from the sun
the daily mail says dementia victims and
their families have paid 14 billion
pounds
towards adult social care since the
prime minister promised
to fix the issue when he assumed office
yorkshire's badly in burst news here's
from kim ledbetter
the sister of the murdered mp joe cox
who has announced her intention
to run as the labour candidate for joe's
former parliamentary seat in an upcoming
by-election
while the ft reports that u.s stocks are
down amid fears the country's economy
could be over inflating well andrew
kevin are here let's start with the ft
shall we not that story about uh the
stock falls but those dramatic pictures
uh we can see from the the latest
conflict in the middle east
words of joe biden tonight he's spoken
spoken to benjamin netanyahu but um
you know for both sides this is uh this
is testing times isn't it andrew
yeah and it's interesting to see now
that the the
the conflict is beginning to edge its
way to the front pages
of some of our newspapers um it's been
an inside page story
so far but these but the images now are
very dramatic
the intervention of the president is
very significant the american president
the foreign secretary spoken again today
defending the right of israel to defend
itself but
begging them to to try to de-escalate
the situation
it's a terrible mess and it's the worst
violence we've seen there
since 2014 and you just get this
horrible feeling
because netanyahu is all at sea he's
prime minister but
only just he hasn't managed to strike a
deal yet
does he want i i mean i care for what i
say here
but does does a military short sharp
military conflict
bolster his position with some of the
more extreme parties who he may then
form
a coalition with yeah i mean you hope
this is not politicking which is sort of
what you're suggesting isn't it
yeah but i mean the roots of this as we
all know goes so deep
uh obviously triggered by recent events
do you see a way out i mean
biden talking about hopes that this will
effectively end
swiftly one wonders what he said to
netanyahu kevin
no that's right and of course the u.s
gives huge military aid
to to israel but um biden
uh will will have to try and get
netanyahu on the side because netanyahu
was busy giving complete free reign by
donald trump who called remove the us
embassy from tel aviv
to uh to jerusalem and cease to have
uh you know any semblance of trying to
be an arbiter and uh
fair play between the two it's an
incredibly intractable
uh dispute this and it's not going to be
resolved militarily for to the
satisfaction of either side
unless they can somehow reach an
agreement on land and security
uh a palestinian state and security for
for israel the deaths are just going to
continue and it will
will be periods when it's uh it's like
this and there'll be
periods when it's calmer there'll be
more periods like this again
and you look at the the ft there has
pictures
of uh flames and uh destruction on both
sides but it's not really
it's not really an equal conflict in the
sense that israel's a nuclear-armed
power
and uh certainly in the gaza and on the
west
the west bank uh they don't have those
weapons uh
probably just as well that they that
they aren't used but there is
destruction i just
there's no there's no way forward for
either side in violence but it's how do
you
reach a settlement to this this dispute
that's in the interests
of both israel and the palestinians
yes and indeed we saw the uh the gaza
night skies lit up by a huge explosion
just in the last hour
so clearly it continues tonight and
we'll we'll keep monitoring that
let's move to here though uh the
pandemic i mean a global issue
but the news today about the date for
the start of this public inquiry
um you know criticism of when but the
detail of this will be
it'll touch so many subjects won't it
andrew
yeah and look there's always going to be
criticism of when he
holds it he says it's going to be start
next spring um and
i think he's it takes a long time to set
up an inquiry of this nature they've got
to sort out the chairman the terms of
reference
it's a serious inquiry people are going
to be giving evidence on
oath and you have to remember the the
chill cut inquiry to the iraq war
finally reported in 2016 13 years after
the war
the inquiry wasn't even set up until
2009 so
going on the recent precedent next year
is pretty quick
because we are almost certainly going to
have another wave of covert in the
winter now
the uh the various modelling uh that's
being done for sage suggests it's not
going to be
anything like as serious as the other
two waves but kobet will still be with
us
the nhs has to be on standby in case it
does get serious
and of course it is convenient for the
prime minister that almost certainly
conclusions of the report of the inquiry
will be published
after there's been a general election
and the people can deliver their own
verdict can't they on whether the
government handled the pandemic well or
not
because there will be a general election
before that uh and
i suspect boris will still be leader
going into that campaign
yes and perhaps no surprise that we get
this announcement after
the election that we saw last week uh
where the vaccine
bubble uh you know prompted people to be
more supportive perhaps of their
governments be it the smp in scotland or
you know labour in wales and uh the
tories here here in
england um but fascinating to that 38
and 39 year olds being asked for the
vaccine biden tonight suggesting parents
should
get their 12 and 15 year olds vaccinated
urgently so we see what happens with the
modeling
but the minutiae of the detail that will
be discussed will be
you know not just the was the lock down
too late was sage too secretive
was the information that came to the
public correct
all of the contracts with ppe and
everything i mean it's just
such a big subject as i said isn't it
kevin
oh no absolutely 127 000 uh
people uh are dead it's it's cost tens
hundreds of million
billions sorry of pounds there should be
an inquiry
i can say i could see no reason for not
setting this up to start in the autumn
the boris johnson's clearly kicked it
into the long grass
um andrew said it was convenient for the
prime minister's very cynical by the
prime minister
as well delaying it until next year and
then until after the next election
because i think the the lessons to be
learned need to be learned publicly
and we need to have a proper proper
debate and sunlight openness
transparency
you'll get better government that way
the chillcott inquiry was far
too late and that it was too long for
that report to come out
that this this pandemic is is here and
now yes
but you can still have an enquiry uh at
the same time prime minister always
seems to have a time to go off and
holidays and mystique played by other
people and
do lots of other things so i can't see
why he can't prepare for an inquiry when
it's his turn
uh to be questioned under oath but now
he's
you know i think he knows why he's
delayed and that's because
so initially and up to last all and
before the
mass uh vaccination program he's not
going to come out at me very well
if he's going to come out of it well
let him let him showboat if that's what
he wants to do but but you know kevin
even if he um
could launch the inquiry in the autumn
uh it most public inquiries take on
average two and a half years
uh and so even then it wouldn't be
reporting back before the general
election because
the fixed term parliament act which was
a ridiculous liberal democrat
uh measure is being abolished so he'll
be calling an election
long before then so i think even if he'd
gone in the autumn we wouldn't get that
report back in time and of course
it could be longer because chillcott
took um three years five years and
it took seven years to report back yeah
let's just move on if you don't mind
because i mean
it's just in some respects some people
suggesting decisions are still being
taken too late for example
india going on the red list and now if
you look at the front page of the
telegraph
an emergency meeting of the government's
sage committee
will convene tomorrow to discuss the
rapid spread of the indian variant now
is that a direct result of making
decisions too late still
and kevin this is worrying isn't it
because it puts in jeopardy the biggest
opening of lockdown we have next week
yeah so what's 727 cases within 45 days
which is three times quicker than the
south african variant uh
and there was some criticism of not
putting india under the red list earlier
and then quarantining people
coming from that these are all lessons
being learned or are they still being
been missed but no you're quite right um
in that telegraph piece they raised
concerns that all restrictions may not
be
lifted uh on june 21st i'll be surprised
if that happens because
the prime minister this year said it was
all about the date and not dates i think
this is about dates not the date and now
i think it's been quite clear for some
for some time but uh if it's gonna
spread rapidly and
if the jabs aren't effective against it
then he he would be judy bound morally
obliged
to actually reconsider that june 21st
deadline in england because of course
will scotland northern ireland going at
their own pace yes indeed and let's go
to the sun then
talking about june the 21st great
british mask off
and i presume some scientists would
prefer we kept
some of those basic measures as they see
it to keep masks on how do you how do
you think you'll feel about
mosques coming off andrew well do you
know i think anna a lot of people have
got so used to wearing a mask now
when you go out of the house now you you
check your keys your phone
your mask uh and um i've got completely
used to it
i if i use public transport i think i'm
gonna wear a mask the whole time
um i wouldn't wear one in the office and
if i go in a shop i think
possibly i would wear a mask i don't
mind it's i don't find it
a huge invasion of my civil liberties
and
um and if you go to countries like
uh uh singapore they and
korea they've been wearing masks for
donkeys years uh in public and in
shopping malls
and they've always had these hand
sanitizers there are two and these those
sort of and those countries
significantly
had a much lower uh covered incidence
than we did and countries in europe so
i i don't mind and actually i've got
some rather nice masks actually
i don't
maybe you can go and get one for us in
the break and uh you know show off one
of your your prime examples
uh see you in just a moment plenty more
still to come including joe cox's sister
plans to stand or try to stand as an mp
back in the moment
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now andrew pearce
and kevin mcguire it'll come eventually
i'm going to start oh there you are
you're back good
um so to the metro and indeed to the mat
cartoon
kevin a small matter of a county court
judgment tell us more
yes this is the 535 pounds county court
judgement six months ago against
boris john johnson listing 10 downing
street as he
as he's addressed so somebody has taken
legal action against the prime minister
because he hasn't allegedly
paid a debt now to get a county called
judgment you have to have proof
you've tried to get the money and you
failed what is the debt
for number 10 say it is nothing to do
with redecoration of the flat
not entirely surprised because it seems
to have got other people to pay
for that taxpayers and and wealthy
people so
what has he not paid
what could this father have not possibly
paid
well downey streets say it's vexatious
downey should say the whole thing is
vexatious and they're going to get it
struck out
but it does feed into the narrative that
boris and his finances are a bit
shambolic but they do
tell us that um it's not a serious claim
i think
i think kevin could could make a claim
against me in the county court
throwing him for airing in money it's
sort of thing he would do actually
i think you can do that but um it's
mysterious
but you can't just invent it you've got
to have you've got to have some proof
that somebody owes you some money
well number 10 say there's nothing
nothing to it whatsoever but
they would refuse to say what the detail
was yeah yeah
number 10 said there's nothing to lots
of things and there's been lots of
things to this
to their so-called dominant comings to
wallpaper the big policy issues around
covered in the
let's see did economy see the mac
cartoon i don't know if we did did we we
haven't got it
we'll try and find that 11 30 when we
have you back um kevin just quick word
on batley and burstal's
news uh about kim ledbetter possibly
standing in this
future by election yeah we don't
normally have this paper on the
uh on the review but it's very welcome
now this is kim ledbetter joe cox's
uh uh sister and labor's uh facing a
very challenging buy election there
because tracy braven the mp
is now the west yorkshire mayor because
she's a police and crime com
sorry because she's got so many uh
responsibilities including
uh police uh she's gonna she's gonna
step down uh she's laid out a stall
uh husband's led bitter saying look i'll
always call the place home uh she seems
to be a prominent local figure
labor have to get this by-election right
and they've got to get the right
candidate in hartlepool they thought
having a covert doctor would trump his
fervent support for brexit in the past
that didn't didn't happen
labor wants a local champion and i think
now ledbetter
is the benchmark can you get anybody
better than her to stand and fight your
court okay didn't quite have time to
look at our final story which we will
uh which is taylor telegraph the
champions league final they say
going to porto because it's quite
interesting and significant
and uh we'll talk more a half eleven
shall we and it's ridiculous
okay it's ridiculous two two english
clubs it should be played in england
okay
we'll see you then thank you
so we're joined then by andrew pearce
and kevin mcguire um quite a range of
stories
uh making the front pages tonight but
lots of news around
not least what's happening in israel and
the gaza strip
andrew in the times fear's mount over
threat of full-scale war in gaza
is their headline despite rather more
promising noises from president
biden tonight um but but it's i mean
it's uncomfortable for for all residents
of both areas isn't it at the moment
yeah yeah it's awful and it's
interesting that the this story is now
moving
closer to the front pages the times has
always been very strong on its foreign
coverage anyway uh and uh it's a big
story
uh biden has made it absolutely clear
the american administration's made it
clear as did um
the foreign secretary today that they
defend israel's right to protect itself
because we know the palestinians are
herding lots of bombs and missiles
into tel aviv and in jerusalem but it's
intractable this problem
and you do wonder with netanyahu's
political future
up in the air yet again i just hope that
he's not using this
in any way the military conflict to
bolster his position perhaps with
some of the more extreme potential
coalition partners
uh i i mean is he politicking for the
sake of it
but um but that biden this is a big test
for biden for
he's the new president uh uh that there
have been very little pressure on israel
from
from uh donald trump and if you see how
much pressure
biden puts on israel remember the united
states are huge
financial benefactors of the state of
israel but
biden i would have thought would be much
less gung-ho about this
than trump yes and indeed after uh mr
biden said
he had hopes this would end sooner
rather than later there had been hopes
of a ceasefire in the territory despite
one enormous explosion we saw
a couple of hours ago um but apparently
uh netanyahu has told both his cabinet
and
and mr biden that actually there will be
no ceasefire
uh and to prepare for more so i mean you
know
depressing and where do we go from here
again kevin
that's right you want people to stop
dying on both sides you want to stop
uh stop people firing rockets bombs and
on on both sides
trump gave netanyahu free reign a green
light do what he liked uh
biden takes a slightly different uh
position and trying to play
an honest broker i think israel gets
about four billion in u.s military
aid i think it's around that per year so
there is some
leverage there but it's not an entirely
uh equal conflict either this
is intractable as uh as andrew says that
peace will have to
resolve it in the end with a formation
of a palestinian independent state
secure israel uh land will have to be
uh dealt with and lots of uh lots of
other issues although
otherwise this will just keep flaring up
but you've got a nuclear-powered
nuclear armed state in israel and you've
got you've got hamas firing these
these rockets from uh from the guard
that's got a strip but if you look at
the death tone it's sort of like six or
seven
higher on the palestinian side than the
israeli side which
is a reflection of the the different
military positions but there is no
military solution in this in the end it
will
have to be a negotiated peace that is in
the interests
of both israelis and palestinians uh so
explosions in gaza are sirens we're told
uh in tel aviv we are we watch and wait
and and see what happens overnight
certainly
um let's move on shall we to covid
uh first of all the idea of this indian
variant uh one of them anyway what
impact that might have on
on the reopening are there genuine
concerns about this now andrew
yeah there are and but you know there
and it makes you wonder why
we didn't get india on the red list for
flights coming in because
we've seen what's been happening in
india the chaos the
the total abject misery of the covid
explosion in india
the variant now the indian variant
that's been discovered in britain
it's doubled and tripled in in number
more more than they wanted
quicker than they expected so far though
the epidemiologists have said that
they're confident
the vaccines can adapt and can contend
with
the indian variant but these variants
mutate
all the time and keep changing all the
time but that's the worry but there is
this emergency stage meeting
uh the and but i suspect um unless
it's there's a real real problem there's
no way the prime minister wants to
uh change that final date of lockdown
being lifted up june the 21st
everything is being geared up for that
in parts of the rest of the papers
tomorrow morning
he's talking about getting people back
to work by june the 21st he wants
people to stop working from home and
he's going to have to start by leading
by example and getting some of those
civil servants
it back in behind their desk because
whitehall is still
a ghost town yes indeed so as as are
many places
uh just a final word in the eye on this
story about the indian variant
um as i said i mean those three three
variants aren't there but one of them
anyway
suggestion there had been suggestion of
localized tears
but the eye suggesting that children
living in the affected areas
could be told to continue wearing face
masks in school or perhaps that's
that is as far as it will get let's go
on to the guardian shall we um a date or
a suggested date for the start of this
public inquiry um too far away still for
for many people but the complexity and
range of this
means there will be a lot of preparation
i suppose kevin
there will uh but you come i'm sure set
this up
in the autumn if you wish pick a pickle
pick a chair pick a panel
uh staff it get a venue give it to terms
of reference
but he's what he's really done the prime
minister he's kicked it into the long
grass by saying it'll start in a year's
time
unlikely to report before the next
election which will be in
2023 the end of 2024 at the very very
latest
he probably doesn't want uh to have to
be examined and he's
his decisions certainly the dawdling and
the dithering the resisting lockdowns to
be
to be looked at again and what lessons
on ppe contract what happened with care
homes
127 000 plus died nhs mass vaccination
program a huge success yes but a lot of
mistakes before then so he doesn't want
it and
the people who seem to be most aggrieved
i think i think
have a right to be so are the other
families of of the dead those who are
mourning and grieving lost
loved ones and they they want to have
their say and they want lessons to be
learned
and to be seen to be learned in public
rather than
behind closed doors or just ignored but
no i think it'd rather
by the prime minister yeah i mean lots
of people point to a pandemic
preparedness
test run back in 2016 which showed that
we weren't ready for a pandemic
but i guess the nhs runs hot doesn't it
andrew
it was always going to be put under
pressure because of the way it operates
yeah yeah and and there was all this
contingency planning for pandemic and
then they did
nothing about it and that was all
happening on the watch of david cameron
theresa may
and jeremy hunt of course he was the
longest serving health secretary but you
know i know
um kevin thinks the prime minister is
deliberately trying to stall this till
after the general election but
you remember the chill cop inquiring to
the iraq war
didn't start until six years after the
iraq war ended and didn't report until
2016 which was
13 years afterward which was an absolute
so
frankly this covert inquiry is almost
rapid by comparison
but even if the prime minister had gone
for it in the autumn
they take on average public inquiries
two and a half years this one is
incredibly complex
very layered and even if he launched it
in the october
or this year i still don't think there'd
be a cat nails chance it would have
reported before the next general
election because
we're getting rid of the stupid liberal
democrat bixter and parliament act
hurrah for that
which means the prime minister can call
an election at his own timing which is
what
blair always did thatcher always did and
uh and so the election will be long
before that report comes out
yeah the minutiae of decision making the
timings of lockdowns
going in and going out of them the
contracts uh contracts awarded for ppe
and other elements
an example of which is back in the
financial times again today kevin
it is and hey what a what a surprise
here we find that andrew feldman a
former tory party chair was an unpaid
advisor to lord bethel health minister
he runs his own lobbying
pr firm and then he pushes and a
contract goes to one of his clients 22.6
million pounds to supply
goggles musks and uh and gowns now of
course uh you know uh impropriety is uh
denied uh
all-round but uh what a coincidence the
firm that supplied the equipment it's
got to be said
was uh already uh working for the nhs in
wales and
in scotland this contract was uh was in
in in england
so it's not like some of the other
companies that just appear being set up
in pubs and so on
but at the the ovip lane it seems if you
knew a tory or you had the
telephone number of a minister you kind
of hit the jackpot and won the lottery
yeah i mean we haven't had the terms of
reference obviously for the inquiry but
will the
allegations of the democracy or whatever
you want to call it be included do you
think
andrew i think it has to be and my
understanding is there's a whole
unit now in the cabinet office working
flat out full-time
already on papers emails texts that will
have to be prepared
for the public inquiry uh and it will be
divided up into various sections and ppe
failure to provide ppe in the first
place the fact that we have to rely on
china
of all places to get ppe don't forget my
newspaper ran a very fine campaign to
get
ppe too but it will be a key time for
that campaign
a key part of that yeah well we actually
have to go where you have to go
but i mean a key part of the campaign
will be the failure to provide pp and
there will also be
the suggestion of the chamocracy doing
rather well don't forget um
the health secretary's pub landlord even
got in on the act
i still can't quite work out that
happened but then no doubt the public
inquiry will tell us more about it yeah
i was surprised to see
lateral flow tests uh imported from
china still
you know i had in my mind we'd be making
them but maybe not yet
uh eventually but uh no doubt it'll all
be all be covered see you in just a
moment
with plenty more including two english
teams playing you probably know this
already in the champions league final
so given curvid why not hold it in
england we will be talking about that
just well welcome back you're watching
the press preview with me now andrew
pearce and kevin mcguire
uh kevin the daily mail headline saying
how we're feeling boris in the bizarre
case of a shock 535 pound
judgment in county court um speculations
filling the gaps here i think isn't it
issued last uh last october private eye
uh broke this uh
story what's it all about number 10 said
it is not to do with the redecorating of
of uh the the dynasty apartment so
there's nothing uh
unusual he's not been up to anything
he's incredibly chaotic but the
uh the male have an explanation
claiming uh that it is from
a uh uh from a covert conspiracy
theorist
who claims he's uh repeatedly slandered
her
and committed repeated uh defamation
and uh as has build him for this uh and
use the uh the online civil monies
claims service which can be as little as
25 pound letters were sent to downing
street
and his name boris not boris johnson not
his real name
alexander uh no reply so this order is
has been given and
the the person behind it according to uh
her majesty's daily mail
uh regularly copies in the queen house
of lords house of commons and bbc to her
complaint
and has also been pursuing rishi soon
i think it's what we call the green ink
brigade i get i get certain letters
which are often
copied to the queen the prime minister
the chance of the exchequer never to
kevin mcguire actually
uh with all these doom and gloom
conspiracy theories and i
and and you know they're they're a bit
mad because some of the writing the
biblical quotations start on the back of
the envelope
you think yeah green ink brigade purple
link brigade
in the bin okay but apparently it's
quite serious though to make um
fraudulent claims about
against somebody but obviously they
didn't think it was fraudulent they
thought they had a good case and we
need to move on very quickly though the
mac cartoon if we have it let's just
have a quick look at that one
uh tell boris that the deck laters debt
collectors have taken the cabinet tables
he is a god isn't he it's a nice touch
isn't it um meanwhile let's go to the
champions league um
andrew do you want to kick off well
listen you know
what i know about football you could
write in the back of a postage stamp but
it is absolutely insane
but top not sorry chelsea and manchester
city are in the final of this european
competition
first of all they had to play the match
in turkey but because turkey's on the
red list it can't go there
but they want to play at wembley stadium
that would be great
but because these uefa officials 2 000
of them want to be on a jolly and a
freebie
because that would affect all the
quarantine rules it's going to be held
in
portugal of all places porto now look
portugal's a very nice country and it's
on the green list but
if you were a top if you were a chelsea
fan or a man city fan
you'd be pretty cross because you
absolutely know the cost of flights to
portugal will be going
through the roof for this match yeah
interesting um
kevin fans of
uh of um manchester city and chelsea
will enjoy it'll be a jolly your way
but you've got to weigh up as the
government like football is a business
uefa has a lot of sponsors and
yeah hangers on and suits who'll want to
go in this game that's 2000 people
if you can get 4 000 people into the
brits last night all taking tests to
show
them beforehand why can't this 2000 have
negative tests because
the you're going to weigh it up you're
either going to have 2 000 people coming
into britain or you're going to have 12
000 people leaving britain and get and
going and going to portugal and then
coming back so there's going to be a mix
of people anyway i i would have thought
it would have been better
to have played it at uh at wembley and
sorted out the arrival of those two
thousand people okay we'll see what the
fans reaction is kevin andrew lovely to
see both thank you